Welcome to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Two, the Danish democracy, Episode One: the constitution, Grundloven.
How does a country run itself?
That is the question this whole chapter answers, and we start with the document that sets the rules of the game.
The Danish democracy has developed over more than one hundred and seventy-five years.
It has been shaped by events and political ideas in Denmark and abroad.
The Danish system of government, the folkestyre, has a lot in common with other European democracies, but it has also found its own special form.
Here is the foundation.
Danish democracy is built on a written constitution: Danmarks Riges Grundlov, usually just called Grundloven.
It deals especially with national democracy, as it takes place in the Folketing, the Danish parliament.
It contains rules about the Folketing, about the government, and about the courts.
The constitution sets certain limits on how the state may use its power, and it secures the citizens a number of fundamental rights.
But Denmark also has a strong tradition of local democracy and self-government.
Local self-government has deep roots in Danish history.
The constitution gives the municipalities, the kommuner, a role in looking after local matters.
Local self-government in the municipalities gives citizens the chance to help decide many things in the local community.
And local democracy shapes many very close everyday matters too.
In a school board, in a housing association, and in various committees at a workplace, you can, as a parent, a resident or an employee, get influence on things that concern your everyday life.
The Danish democracy has many different players, each with their own roles, views and interests.
Organisations and associations are also part of political life.
That can be labour market organisations such as the Danish Trade Union Confederation, FH, and the Danish Employers' Confederation, DA, or business or environmental organisations, which all consist of a long list of trade unions, employers' associations and interest organisations.
The Folketing, the Supreme Court and several ministries are all located on Slotsholmen in Copenhagen.
Now let's open the constitution itself.
The framework of Danish democracy is laid down in Danmarks Riges Grundlov, which is Denmark's constitution.
It is a fairly short text, with a total of eighty-nine paragraphs, which contain the basic rules and principles of the Danish state's form of government.
The constitution also secures the population a number of fundamental rights and freedoms.
Denmark got its first democratic constitution on the fifth of June, 1849.
That is why this date is Constitution Day, Grundlovsdag.
For almost two hundred years before that, since sixteen sixty to sixty-one, the country had been ruled by an absolute king on the basis of the King's Law of 1665.
When the constitution was adopted, the king's power was shared with elected representatives.
The constitution of 1849 is a foundation that has since been gradually built on.
Only with the Change of System in 1901 did the king have to accept that the Folketing decides who should have government power.
This system is called parliamentarism.
Who could vote at the beginning?
Only men over thirty years old.
They must not have received poor relief and must not have been declared legally incapable.
They also had to have a fixed place of residence and be of good repute.
Women and servants, that is, people without their own household, who served and lived with another family, did not get the vote.
This only happened with the constitution of 1915.
Since then, the voting age for the Folketing has gradually been lowered from thirty years down to the present voting age of eighteen years, which was adopted in 1978.
Now, a set of key dates.
The constitution has been changed in 1866, 1915, 1920 and 1953.
The current constitution is therefore from 1953.
Much has changed in Denmark over the last one hundred and seventy-five years.
But many of the principles, and large parts of the text of the newest constitution, go all the way back to the constitution of 1849.
It is often emphasised that the constitution is a firm but roomy framework around Danish democracy.
It is worded so generally that political life has been able to change without it being necessary to change the provisions of the constitution.
The constitution is meant to help secure political stability and protect citizens' fundamental rights.
That is why it has been made very difficult to change.
The constitution can only be changed if there is support from both the Folketing and the population.
That ensures, among other things, that a random political majority cannot take a minority's fundamental rights away from it, or introduce a completely different form of government.
The constitution of 1953 still bears the mark of the language of 1849.
It uses words and expressions that are not common today.
If you read the constitution, you can easily get the impression that the king still plays a big political role.
But the rules of the constitution are interpreted in practice in such a way that the king's power has been taken over by the government.
The language of the constitution is one of the reasons why it has at times been debated whether the constitution should be changed to fit the present better.
It has also been discussed whether it should be better at protecting basic freedoms and human rights, and whether the rules for Denmark's participation in international cooperation should be changed.
Many, however, think there is no reason to change a well-functioning constitution that allows adaptation to the times.
In fact, it is very difficult, and perhaps almost impossible, to change the constitution because of the strict requirements.
The fifth of June is called Constitution Day and is celebrated every year as a national day of celebration, with political meetings all over the country.
So what does the constitution say?
The constitution is the highest law in Denmark.
The Folketing and the government must therefore respect it, and must not do anything contrary to it.
It sets the most important rules of the game for national democracy.
The constitution contains rules about: the state's highest bodies, the Folketing, the government and the courts, and the relationship between them.
The election of members of the Folketing.
The adoption of laws.
The Danish state's relationship to the outside world.
The Danish national church, the folkekirke.
Local self-government.
And the citizens' fundamental rights.
Denmark has a representative democracy.
That means the population elects representatives to the Folketing, who then make decisions on behalf of the people.
The elected stand accountable to the voters on election day.
It is the voters who decide whether the individual party or politician should be elected again.
Democracy in Denmark is thus predominantly an indirect democracy.
However, referendums are also held.
Here the population can directly take a stand on a specific political question.
In Danish democracy, parliamentarism applies.
That means a government cannot be formed, or stay in power, if it has a majority in the Folketing against it.
Since the voters decide how the Folketing is composed, the voters also decide who should have government power.
In 1953, this parliamentary principle was written into the text of the constitution itself.
The power of the state is divided in three: a legislative power, an executive power and a judicial power.
This separation of powers was introduced with the constitution of 1849, which abolished the king's absolute power.
The separation of powers means that the government and the Folketing together make laws, the legislative power.
It is the government that, through the ministries, administers the laws in practice and puts them into effect, the executive power.
The third power is the courts, the judicial power.
They settle conflicts between citizens, and between citizens and the state.
It is also the courts that pass judgment in criminal cases.
The basic idea is that the three powers should control and limit each other's exercise of power.
The separation of powers is, in other words, meant to ensure that power in society does not become centralised or misused.
The division protects citizens against arbitrary interference.
This separation of powers exists in different versions in most democratic countries.
Now, the head of state.
Denmark's head of state is a monarch, that is, a king or, as in the period 1972 to 2024, a queen.
The monarch's position is inherited and does not give any political power.
The monarch and the other members of the royal family have especially a number of ceremonial tasks, and tasks as representatives of Denmark.
The royal house represents, for example, official Denmark in relation to foreign heads of state.
The political power is exercised solely by the government and the Folketing.
It is the same in other European monarchies like Sweden, Norway, Belgium and Great Britain.
So Denmark does not have an elected, and politically powerful, head of state like the presidents of France and the USA.
Queen Margrethe the Second, born 1940, reigned from 1972 to 2024.
A photo in the chapter shows her receiving Ukraine's president Volodymyr Zelensky and his wife Olena on a state visit to Denmark in 2023.
The constitution also contains a rule that Danish citizenship, indfødsret, can only be granted by law.
That means it is the government and the majority of the Folketing who decide which foreigners can be granted Danish citizenship.
The constitution also secures and protects several fundamental freedoms and human rights.
This includes the right to freely express your opinions under responsibility before the courts, freedom of expression, ytringsfrihed.
The right to meet with others, freedom of assembly, forsamlingsfrihed.
And the right to form associations.
The constitution also protects personal freedom, freedom of religion, the right of property, and the privacy of private life.
These rights protect the individual citizen, and the minority, against the majority misusing its power.
Here is your recap for Episode One.
Denmark's constitution, Grundloven, has eighty-nine paragraphs.
The first democratic constitution was adopted on the fifth of June, 1849, so the fifth of June is Constitution Day.
It has been changed in 1866, 1915, 1920 and 1953, and the current one is from 1953.
It can only be changed with support from both the Folketing and the population.
Women got the vote with the constitution of 1915.
The voting age of eighteen was adopted in 1978.
The parliamentary principle was written into the constitution in 1953.
The power of the state is divided into the legislative, executive and judicial powers, introduced in 1849.
Denmark has a representative democracy, with a monarch as head of state without political power.
And Danish citizenship can only be granted by law.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
When was the constitution last changed?
Option A: 1849.
Option B: 1920.
Option C: 1953.
[DA] Hvornår blev grundloven sidst ændret?  A: 1849  |  B: 1920  |  C: 1953
The answer is C: 1953.
It appeared in the June 2020 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: 1953
Question 2.
When was Denmark's Constitution introduced?
Option A: 1849.
Option B: 1814.
Option C: 1789.
[DA] Hvornår blev Danmarks Riges Grundlov indført?  A: 1849  |  B: 1814  |  C: 1789
The answer is A: 1849.
It appeared in the November 2020 and May 2024 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: 1849
Question 3.
Which day is celebrated on the fifth of June?
Option A: The Queen's birthday.
Option B: Denmark's liberation.
Option C: Constitution Day, Grundlovsdag.
[DA] Hvilken mærkedag fejres den 5. juni?  A: Dronningens fødselsdag  |  B: Danmarks befrielse  |  C: Grundlovsdag
The answer is C: Constitution Day, Grundlovsdag.
It appeared in the November 2020 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Grundlovsdag
Question 4.
Which day is Constitution Day in Denmark?
Option A: The fifth of June.
Option B: The fifteenth of June.
Option C: The twenty-third of June.
[DA] Hvilken dag er det grundlovsdag i Danmark?  A: Den 5. juni  |  B: Den 15. juni  |  C: Den 23. juni
The answer is A: The fifth of June.
It appeared in the June 2022 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Den 5. juni
Question 5.
Through which constitutional amendment did women get the vote for the Folketing?
Option A: The amendment of 1866.
Option B: The amendment of 1915.
Option C: The amendment of 1953.
[DA] Ved hvilken grundlovsændring fik kvinder valgret til Folketinget?  A: Grundlovsændringen i 1866  |  B: Grundlovsændringen i 1915  |  C: Grundlovsændringen i 1953
The answer is B: The amendment of 1915.
It appeared in the November 2020, June 2021 and June 2022 exams.
[DA] ✔ B: Grundlovsændringen i 1915
Question 6.
What was adopted with the constitutional amendment of 1915?
Option A: That women could inherit the Danish throne.
Option B: That women got the vote for the Folketing.
Option C: That women had to serve conscription.
[DA] Hvad blev vedtaget med grundlovsændringen i 1915?  A: At kvinder fik mulighed for at arve den danske trone  |  B: At kvinder fik stemmeret til Folketinget  |  C: At kvinder skulle aftjene værnepligt
The answer is B: That women got the vote for the Folketing.
It appeared in the May 2025 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: At kvinder fik stemmeret til Folketinget
Question 7.
Did women get the vote for the Folketing with the constitution of 1849?
Option A: Yes.
Option B: No.
[DA] Fik kvinder valgret til Folketinget med grundloven i 1849?  A: Ja  |  B: Nej
The answer is B: No.
It appeared in the November 2023 and November 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ B: Nej
Question 8.
Between whom are the legislative, the executive and the judicial power divided?
Option A: The Folketing, the government and the courts.
Option B: The Folketing, the regions and the courts.
Option C: The government, the regions and the municipalities.
[DA] Hvem er den lovgivende, den udøvende og den dømmende magt fordelt mellem?  A: Folketinget, regeringen og domstolene  |  B: Folketinget, regionerne og domstolene  |  C: Regeringen, regionerne og kommunerne
The answer is A: The Folketing, the government and the courts.
It appeared in 4 different exams, most recently in November 2025.
[DA] ✔ A: Folketinget, regeringen og domstolene
Question 9.
Who holds the judicial power?
Option A: The Folketing.
Option B: The government.
Option C: The courts.
[DA] Hvem har den dømmende magt?  A: Folketinget  |  B: Regeringen  |  C: Domstolene
The answer is C: The courts.
It appeared in the November 2020 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Domstolene
Question 10.
Which right is secured in the constitution?
Option A: The right to a holiday.
Option B: The right to own hunting weapons.
Option C: The right to express oneself.
[DA] Hvilken rettighed er sikret i grundloven?  A: Retten til at holde ferie  |  B: Retten til at eje jagtvåben  |  C: Retten til at ytre sig
The answer is C: The right to express oneself.
It appeared in the November 2022 and June 2026 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: Retten til at ytre sig
Question 11.
Which right is secured in the constitution?
Option A: The right to form an association.
Option B: The right to carry a weapon.
Option C: The right to a holiday.
[DA] Hvilken rettighed er sikret i grundloven?  A: Retten til at danne en forening  |  B: Retten til at bære et våben  |  C: Retten til at holde ferie
The answer is A: The right to form an association.
It appeared in the November 2020 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Retten til at danne en forening
Question 12.
From which country did Denmark receive a state visit by a president in August 2023?
Option A: France.
Option B: India.
Option C: Ukraine.
[DA] Fra hvilket land modtog Danmark statsbesøg af en præsident i august 2023?  A: Frankrig  |  B: Indien  |  C: Ukraine Spørgsmål 40-45 angår danske værdier
The answer is C: Ukraine.
It appeared in the November 2023 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Ukraine Spørgsmål 40-45 angår danske værdier
That's the end of this part.
Well done.